we all like a better of good life some
the money some the drugs others the sex
game the glamour or the fame a kid who
has everything
parties Super
Y I'm going to inherit more money than
most people could earn or spend in a
lifetime it would be a low estimate a
very low estimate for me to say 20
billion growing up rich is the dream
your parents buy you anything you want
you go to the best schools you only hang
out with other Rich Kids you get to
party with all the right people as a
rich could you never experience any
hardship life is as good as it gets or
is it I've always hated how just because
someone is born into a family of wealth
people automatically label them as a
spoiled brat yes my dad has a private
jet and I love flying in it yes my dad
has a mansion and cars and I love making
videos with them who wouldn't but I have
never pretended that those things were
something that I earned just to give
people context okay so I was born in one
of the poorest countries in the world
and then I I grew up in one of the
poorest communities ities in the United
States I'm fully aware of the criticism
and I've also seen the other side of
things which is like as an adult you
know most of the people I deal with tend
to be you know very wealthy individuals
or very wealthy families and so I've
seen both sides of the extremes and
after seeing everything I would say that
I have never seen a single person from a
poor Community even remotely as mentally
ill as kids from Rich families like you
can't even compare the two however uh
much you feel like your parents are
might be disappointed in you you you
multiply that by a billion and now you
understand what it's like to grow up as
a rich kid so um again I'm saying this
as someone who's been to the extremes of
both ends you just can't compare the two
like I I would absolutely if I had to
like uh start life over again I would
absolutely choose to start again in in a
super poor community and live in a poor
Community for the rest of my life then
to have to start life in a rich
community and deal with all the
pressures and consequences but why why
are rich kids so miserable and mentally
ill stay dangerous and let's find
out
the first step in understanding the
misery of rich kids is to understand
that by just being alive right now you
are already one of the richest people in
history you know most of us um
technically we wealthier than most of
human history simply by the fact that
most of us have access to clean water to
a wide range of foods we have
electricity we have you know we have air
conditioning heating like all these
random things that we take for granted
that by definition would make us
wealthier than most humans that have
ever existed and yet although we are
technically Filthy Rich compared to our
ancestors we don't feel rich because all
of this is normal to us and that's
exactly what it's like for rich kids
growing up the Mansions the cars the
clothes the fancy Sports and black tii
events this is their normal growing up
and because it was their normal growing
up they have no idea that they're rich
growing up they don't view themselves as
anything special they just look at their
rich friends and their parents rich
friends and they just assume that the
entire world is like that my dad brought
us up always telling us we were poor I
was fairly average and I didn't know my
dad had a lot of money until I turned 15
I didn't always know I was rich I know
it sounds a little strange to say that
but growing up in the country I just
thought that everybody had carriages and
horses and stuff like that I mean what
did I do to earn the kind of money I'll
own at midnight tonight all I did was
inherit it I mean growing up everything
just seems normal you go to a museum
you're like yeah that's me that's my
family you know
and don't you have a family museum my
mom had never really been on the subway
I took her on the other day and she was
like wo this is cool other people should
do this and although it may sound like
they're just so out of touch well yeah
that is exactly the point if you grew up
without knowing any other way of life
you wouldn't have anything to compare
your lifestyle to how would you have any
idea that things could be different for
other people the answer is you wouldn't
and you won't find out until you
graduate from your bubble and you get
pushed out into the real world where
you're forced to actually make something
out of yourself and that's when you get
a giant slap in the face and then you go
out into into the real world and you're
told that you now need to make your own
money and you very quickly you realize
that it's incredibly difficult to make
the kind of money that your parents made
or your grandparents made and now you
went from what was normal to you to now
feeling like you're in extreme poverty B
compared to what you what you're used to
what do you think what would you do if
like you lost all your money toor I
don't know it's it's kind of like well
I'm not going to compare it to that but
it is in the same way like the idea of
losing a parent or a sibling and now
you're in this extremely insecure
situation where like imagine for anyone
watching like if you suddenly went from
your existing situation and your
existing Comforts to going into to you
know living in the woods basically for
the next two years by yourself I think
the dynamic is uh kind of a mixed
feelings is mostly a sad one where you
know you're you're grateful but then now
you feel like a failure so you end up
feeling guilty a lot of the time and you
also feel uh like you're in some sort of
rush to now get rich quick and given
that weird dynamic of extreme guilt and
and this heavy rush you just keep
running on a treadmill and you never
actually get anywhere in life I did I
did a portrait for princess FAL Jordan
mandalina Thea copas Alexandra bun
firstenberg I just did one of Alex and
toita Bun firstenberg this one is very
sort of bash what does that set read
I will spend the rest of my life trying
to live up to ideals I don't think I can
and then and then they start pressuring
you to actually marry someone that they
think you know is is also High status
which which again like creates a weird
pressure on you preup it's been drilled
into my head since I was 5 years old
prup that becomes a huge contentious
part you know in most rich families outs
says like who you end up marrying and
overall the actual day-to-day experience
though is one where the rich kid himself
or herself just feels like a nobody and
some of them you know might end up
blaming their parents or oftentimes
their grandparents and you see this with
with Luke
Skywalker but like um uh because they
feel so insecure and they feel like such
a nobody they it might turn into enough
anger where they want to scapegoat their
parents or scapegoat whoever it is in
the family that made them rich and the
perfect example of this is from a
documentary called born rich which
you've been seeing throughout this video
highly recommend Bor and Rich was made
by a rich kid named Jamie Johnson who is
part of the insanely wealthy Johnson and
Johnson Dynasty and the one thing his
family hated the most was talking about
money but because Jamie Johnson probably
had similar feels to what arva just
described Jamie Johnson needed to Rebel
he needed to figuratively kill his
father and so he produced a documentary
exposing what it's actually like to be
born rich so I was just kind of a mess I
was weird I mean some of my friends tell
me about how I used to just go off in
the woods and climb up up to the very
top of a tree and sort of make weird
noises and scare people I mean the first
time I tried LSD was the summer we are
on the 68th floor okay ready for me to
look totally um I've needless
to say his family and the other families
he exposed were not very happy and
honestly for the parents they're not
mentally doing okay either like they're
like losing it in terms of like making
sure that they're not failures as
parents so most of the parents of rich
kids they I've never really met one that
doesn't feel like a complete on some
level because they feel like it was
their responsibility to ensure that
their kid was high achieving and
successful and they invested all this
time and energy and money into it but
you know let's say the kid ends up like
a normal functioning person in society
that to them implies that they did a bad
job compared to these you know other
Rich parents where their kids ended up
let's say going into the family business
and becoming even wealthier and those
parents like what you see in like the TV
shows they really are going to these
stupid parties and like you know
bragging and and all this nonsense
usually it's not a fun situation for
anyone involved and so you'll often
times find this like uh lawsuit cases
with these you know multi-billion dollar
families and they're suing each other
for like 10 20 years they just don't
stop suing each other like the family
internal conflict is huge especially
when the amount of money inside the
family is large enough to where it can
spread across many people the conflict
that ends up happening is almost
unbelievable it's like you know much
crazier than anything you'd see in TV
shows or movies what I find interesting
is that what you said if you grow up in
a Absol Ely poor family like literally
anything you do above that your parents
will be super super proud of you but if
you grow up in a rich family then it's
practically impossible to like get
higher than them yeah and they want you
to somehow you know start back from zero
and then climb up and then go higher
than it's like a it's functionally
impossible situation so it's almost
guaranteed that you know if you're the
the kid of a really wealthy parents like
you know you're likely going to have a
lot of mental issues they end up being
extremely insecure people usually they
act really weird I'm not you know a fan
of dealing with most some of them are
very nice people I genuinely like them
but I haven't found that they're like in
any way evil it's just they tend to be
very insecure individuals they never
kind of mentally feel like they're
worthy or they've accomplished enough
and it's kind of a sad thing okay but
even if they're super insecure and
depressed and lonely I mean they got it
end up successful right that's got to be
a guarantee right well not
quite
[Music]
do rich kids have like a higher
likelihood of success in general
compared to like you know if you grew up
four or whatever like what's the general
outcome of the rich kids like do they
end up successful so on average what
happens is that they're really well
taken care of through the private school
system so they tend to go to the most
elite private schools and they have you
know even for the SAT they have tutors
that they pay $1,000 an hour for they
have very sort of elite access to things
and especially Elite access to knowledge
that allows them to get into Elite
universities and on top of that you know
if they have enough family connections
or if their family is that wealthy that
they donate to the universities they're
almost guaranteed to get into a top
university now once they're at the elite
University the problem is they're just
like everybody else like they're just
some normal person because at the end of
the day no matter how Elite of an
education you get if you were B born
with a silver spoon in your mouth the
chances of you having the same drive and
motivation as the patriarch of your
family when he was poor is close to a
fat zero so they try to go into Wall
Street they try to go into Consulting
they might try to go into Tech but
something where you know they can get a
job and it feels High status enough like
it feels tracked like it's like okay hey
I went to Harvard now I work at
Mackenzie or I work at Facebook or I
work at Goldman Sachs like no one's
going to think you're a failure
generally speaking they end up in a
comfortable corporate job and it's very
rare that they become truly successful
independent entrepreneurs all you're
doing from that point forward is just
working super hard to finally feel
comfortable again and that's how the
rich people kind of go through life they
work really really hard for many years
just trying to get back to the standard
of living that they were used to when
they were kids because that to them was
just normal it's not like they feel like
they're really successful at any point
really and more importantly than that
they tend to start to resent either
their parents or or their grandparents
very commonly whoever often times like
you know made the family wealthy it
tends to be the grandparents but that's
kind of an easy scapegoat and they
really resent them and they feel like
they can't live up to their family's
expectations and that is the path a lot
of rich kids take they get a very
comfortable but High status corporate
job but I mean come on with that kind of
isolation insecurity and resentfulness
many Rich Kids end up taking a much
darker path which brings us the path
number two drugs lots and lots of drugs
believe me the things that you're not
allowed to do are always the most
fun yes La is crazy so it it's very easy
for me to fall into the Trap of partying
a lot more than I should have been I
mean the first time I tried LSD was the
somewh between sixth and seventh grade
most of them you know they're they they
tend to be um uh really into drugs and
whatever but that's not a bad thing or
that's not a good thing it's just that
they do it not for fun they do it
because they're so miserable and that's
kind of a big distinction is in a lot of
other um income levels people might take
drugs because they are uh bored or they
they um uh uh just want to do it for fun
but with Rich Kids like the real reason
they're doing it is actually because
they hate their lives so much to such a
degree usually that they can't tolerate
going through day by day or they'll go
down path number three where they chase
Fame at any cost this is the habit of
rich kids is they want the the only
Outlets that they have is either they
become depressed alcoholics um or or
drug addicts and they're like sad and
depressed their whole lives until they
die or they focus obsessively on trying
to become famous because it's the only
way they can be significant most wealthy
families like the Johnson and Johnson
family need to be under the radar
because if you have billions well you'll
probably have to do a lot of sketchy
things to make those billions and you
definitely have a lot of leeches and
enemies trying to tear you down so
attention is the last thing you want I
mean you're dealing with families that
have always made it gospel that you
don't talk about your money as a rich
kid getting some quick attention is a
lot easier than making a billion dollars
on your own I once met a girl on a night
out flew it to Aba with me the next day
and married her on a Sunday we divorced
a week later and if you don't take any
of those paths then you might just end
up killing your father that's kind of
the main thing like that luk Skywalker
thing of like trying to uh show yourself
as the good guy and then your dad's the
bad guy that's like a very not it might
not be their dad but it's very commonly
like their grandfather or somebody um
that created the wealth it's usually
easy for them to resort to saying that
that guy's a bad guy and then try to
throw them under the bus in the process
um or or Rebel somehow yeah I think it
can actually give you more drive but a
lot of times that's turned towards
revenge like showing up your family like
seeing you know I told you so look what
I can do that's why you see sometimes
you know wealthy kids turn to drugs or
you hang out with really whack job
people because they want to shock their
family they want to show that they can
escape from the mole that their family
all seems to be a part of I mean
personally the way I'm going about that
is because I plan to actually grad
college and go to graduate school and
you know and you know thumb my nose up
at them with a PhD and something that's
it I mean that's my little form of
Revenge but with all that being said
there are still a very few select rich
kids that do become more successful than
their patriarch the only time that
they're very successful entrepreneurs is
if they have the uh humility to realize
how difficult it is to be such a
successful entrepreneur and instead go
into the family business and take on the
family business into the next
Generations and so those tend to be the
Rich Kids that actually uh create a lot
of wealth because they can take an
existing business and now you know learn
from it add on to it and that is the the
best thing that someone can do if
they're coming from a very wealthy
family is go into the family business
there is a unique subset um where uh
essentially in their uh family
generations and in their culture they're
forced to really be an entrepreneur
since they're in elementary school so
they learn entrepreneurship from a very
very young age and they're and they are
able to actually create businesses from
scratch and um uh that's a very rare
exception a great example of this is how
everyone's favorite billionaire George
Soros is having his son takeover and how
his son already has easy access to the
White House but keep in mind for every
Alexander Soros there is there are tens
of thousands of other rich kids who are
complete failures and let's be real
being the son of an actual psychopath
billionaire can't be all that fun
[Laughter]
either
[Music]
so what is the takeaway from all this is
that although being born poor may feel
like a curse it's actually the biggest
blessing you could have ever asked for
because you have nowhere to go but up
arv was born in one of the poorest
countries in the world and then he grew
up in one of the poorest communities in
the US I was born in Vietnam we came in
when I was two when we had nothing we
lived in low-income housing I remember
we would have to catch the bus and bring
our own soda into McDonald's to save
money and only order off the dollar menu
no combo meals and I was so embarrassed
of it growing up but that's exactly what
gave me the dve to be where I'm at today
same where arbit and here's the thing
every single inch that we Ascend up the
ranks of society we get to feel every
single ounce of fulfillment from it and
it's honestly the best drug in the world
but when you're born rich when you're
born that high up in the clouds well you
have literally nowh to go but down so
don't envy the rich kids be extremely
grateful you're not one of them